in the final scene of the last Harry
Potter movie Harry Ron and Hermione send
their kids off to Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry and that's where
the new Broadway play Harry Potter and
the cursed child picks up JK Rowling's
beloved characters or adults and their
kids are having adventures at Hogwarts
rolling stone calls the play a thrilling
triumph of epic proportions that will
soon be the stuff of legend the New York
Times says it raises the bar for
Broadway magic the two-part 5 our play
is nominated for 10 count them 10 Tony
Awards it already won a record 9 Olivier
Awards in England that includes Tony
nominations and Olivier wins for Jaime
Parker who plays Harry Potter and Noma
do bez Winnie who plays Hermione Granger
Jamie and Noma good morning so my old
review should be read in that voice so a
lot of this is shrouded in secrecy
tell us about Harry where this starts
off well like you say we can pick out
from the end of the book so they're
their parents now we're all parents were
packing our kids off after Hogwarts and
it's sort of next generation of
adventures but the if the books are
about coming of age and coming into your
own as a person then the next thing is
about how to become a parent when nobody
has ever really taught you how in sort
of living up to his father's reputation
and expectations yeah sure and he you
know Harry's nearly twice the age that
his father ever made it to in this place
so you know with the with no role model
everybody keeps dying on him so you know
how does he do it no more your casting
was a big surprise for a lot of people
what was that guy yeah she's a person of
color people were clutching their pearls
when they found out that you were cast I
know and how did you handle that and
what did you think because you were a
die-hard Harry Potter fan yes you know
characters my joy is and that's the only
way I could get to explain it is when
John Tiffany and Sonia Friedman said we
love you to do this part I was like
that's amazing because I've had the most
extraordinary time in the workshops and
the group of actors that I got to meet
and I'm a few of us from the workshop
Jamie I met later on on the I'm late to
the party but we'd work with each other
but it's a Jewish thing I happen to be I
love the web that I do I am a woman of
color and I got the job and it's that's
the biggest privilege I can have how
other people dealt with that yeah
there's other people's stuff as my
friend Jocelyn said no ma you could have
been awful it's a joyous thing it's
2018-2019 and yes and my child is
growing outgoing thank you you get to
play your money and I love your films
and I love the stories so we're just
doing our jobs
yeah and and thanks for being here on
your day off you're both stepping into
roles people have all of these notions
about whatever that like well I mean I
could only think of one other example
where you get seven volumes of backstory
before you come on stage with you and
you know people don't know Richard the
third as well as they know Harry the
Potter Harry dupatta having Harry the
bottom yeah so I mean the main thing is
just kind of the blueprint is there and
just get out of the way because when do
you ever have an audience there's this
big and this hungry to make this sort of
theatrical reality take flight and they
come in their imaginations are ready to
go and they're prat so it's yeah I just
kind of kind of try and step out of the
way of it to be honest it's amazing what
happens on the stage though I'm in it
it's a type of thing that I wish I had a
rewind button so I could say how did
they do that but it's interesting that
the audiences are keeping the secrets
why do you think that these are doing
that lovely version of that is because
you kind of go why would you be cruel to
somebody else you've said that why would
you support someone else is fun because
people repeat normal people are mean
waits when they've been loved they
aren't but I mean isn't isn't doesn't
that give you hope
I mean you you've got you've had
Elizabeth Warren hitting here
on here this morning and we're talking
about the best-selling literary series
ever written you know so apparently when
it comes to literary series more than
anything else in the world human beings
want to read this story which
fundamentally has kindness it's at the
heart of its narrative that gives me a
lot of hope because it's our narratives
and our fictions that allow us to build
the institutions by which we can
cooperate gigantic numbers very well and
if you've got a narrative like that at
the heart of it led by you know whoever
then then that gives us Jamie Parker
2020 Bank Harry Potter curse child
playing now The Lyric Theatre in New
York and you can watch the 72nd annual
Tony Awards for medio City Music Hall in
New York